bonjour c'est un plaisir pour moi d'être
avec vous aujourd'hui cet après midi
pour parler de l'audace tu rêves
montréal
permettez-moi de revenir un peu en
arrière
en 2007 le 21 juin 2007-mai fia morial
une petite fille qui s'appelle chloé la
même année quelques jours plus tard en
fait tu n'essaies à alep en syrie
un petit garçon nommé calais aujourd'hui
sept ans plus tard
chloé va à l'école primaire est en
deuxième année dans le quartier ahuntsic
elle vit avec son père et avec sa mère
pas de frères et soeurs aujourd'hui
khaled vie au liban il a été une des
victimes de toutes les massacres qui ont
eu lieu au lit en syrie est aujourd'hui
sa famille a été déplacé il a perdu son
père il vit avec ses trois autres frères
et soeurs qui sont plus jeunes que lui
avec sa mère et malheureusement ne va
pas à l'école
pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce que
je crois qu'on a une chance inouïe
d'habiter le pays que l'on habite
d'habiter la ville que l'on habite cette
ville a permis à des gens comme chloé
finalement de pouvoir atteindre des
rêves est ce que l'on veut utilement
quand je parle de rêve montréalais c'est
de vraiment pouvoir s'assurer que tout
le monde atteigne son plein potentiel
on a donc une chance inouïe de vivre ici
mais le rêve que l'on caresse de
permettre à chacun d'atteindre son plein
potentiel c'est un rêve qu'il faut
constamment alimentés c'est un rêve
qu'il faut constamment nourrir
c'est un rêve qui elle nécessite trois
ingrédients importants
je vais vous parler du premier
ingrédient le premier ingrédient le
premier à celle en bi sion ils font
qu'on permette à tous de voir grand il
faut qu'on ait de l'ambition pour nous
mêmes mais également pour l'ensemble de
notre société et l'ambition comme je
disais tout à l'heure de jeu
c'est de voir grand ça doit transcender
les individus mais je connais personne
qui a une ambition pour une société qui
n'est pas une ambition qui lui soit
propre et personnel et c'est vrai
partage est avec vous une histoire qui
l'a beaucoup marqué en 1984
est-ce que vous rappelle que c'est parce
qu'en 1984 à montréal le pape jean paul
ii est venu à mon frère et moi j'avais
10 ans et dans mes cours de catéchèse
avait été délégué par ma classe pour
rencontrer le pape alors vous imaginez
je suis rentré à la maison dire à mes
parents d'origine haïtienne catholique
que j'allais rencontrer le pape
c'était la fête ils ont appelé ma
famille en haïti ma grand-mère est
débarqué pour le jour j
c'était une grande aventure à la maison
et on me préparait donc par rob était
prête mais j'étais bien coiffé pour
aller rencontrer le pape
une seule chose que j'avais mentionné la
personne n'avait vraiment pris au
sérieux c'est la question
on m'avait dit le ministre et dans une
question quand tu vas rencontrer le pape
jeudi je préparais ma question mais
personne ne m'avait demandé crédité
cette question le jour est arrivé on t'a
l'église notre dame
il y avait des enfants partout du monde
partout et là je suis dans l'enceinte de
l'église notre dame et on attend le pape
et arrive le pape et le pape
s'installent ils festoient et là on
demande est ce que quelqu'un une
question pour la partie oui devenir pose
la question alors je regarde le pape et
je lui dis cher pape est ce que je peux
moi-même être pape
le saint père me regardent se lève
le programme met sa main sur ma joue
mais ça met sa tête et me dit on enfin
tu es béni
c'était que d'autres cas une question
pour le pape
on n'a pas répondu à ma question et
notamment dominique sais pas si on va
passer d'une pièce alors je rentre à la
maison il y avait des images de moi la
télévision mes parents étaient dans un
état d'effervescence ma grand mère sa
fille sa petite fille avait été bénis
par le pape
et moi j'avais halimi ne peut pas
déconfite m'a pas déçu et mon père et à
me voir et me dire 2010 ça tape alerte a
pas l'air content d'avoir rencontré pas
tu te mets à pas je peux pas être est ce
qu'on ne taille pas je vais non après je
pense pas que je savais que je veux
partager poser la question n'a pas
répondu parce que je savais que je
pouvais pas être et mon père m'a dit de
minutes tu sauras que ce n'est pas le
pape qui décide qui est pas soit pas te
laisser impressionner par le pas il ya
déjà eu une papesse par le passé elle
s'appelait la papesse jeanne pourquoi je
vous parle de ça parce que l'ambition
n'a pas de limites et que même si
aujourd'hui j'ai le malheur de vous dire
que je n'ai pas atteint la papauté
il reste que pour toutes les clauses et
du monde et pour tout
mais qu'allait du monde ce que l'on veut
c'est qu'ils verraient grand c'est
qu'ils aient des rêves qu'il dépasse
d'abord eux mêmes et dépasse les
frontières pour vraiment qu'on puisse
atteindre une société qui est elle
l'échelle de nos rêves
c'était premier ingrédient le deuxième
ingrédient dont j'aimerais vous parler
audace je pourrais aussi faire comme ça
audace l'audace c'est de faire les
choses différemment
l'audace c'est de briser les status quo
pour voir comment on peut faire les
choses d'une manière qui n'a jamais été
c'est par le passé l'audace et de
remettre en question des idées qui ont
été acquises et les idées qui sont
souvent aussi préconçues l'audace c'est
de penser différemment et souvent ce qui
nous empêche de penser ce qui nous
empêche l'arrivée c'est notre confiance
en soi c'est la confiance que l'on a en
nom propre moyen c'est la modestie
cette modestie que j'appelle cette
maladie contagieuse dont il faut guérir
la modestie n'est pas zone atout la
modestie n'est pas une qualité c'est à
défaut alors cette modestie il faut s'en
débarrasser
ça commence très jeune et c'est cette
année que mon fils et les cas maintenant
sept ans m'a servi une bonne leçon en
matière en matière d'eau as on faisait
un travail avec lui à l'école alors il a
remis le devoir et il devait se définir
il devait dire est ce qu'il est drôle
est-ce qu'il est curieux est-ce qu'il
est fatigant est-ce qu'il est excité ce
que les sportifs y donner c'est de
définir l'âge de michael faut que tu te
définis ça leur demande qu'est ce que tu
es là tu es drôle des curieux alors tous
- qualificatif la tunique à elle
réfléchit et une des mamans je pense que
je suis fantastique
et ça pour moi c'était le plus beau
cadeau du monde parce que cet enfant là
je me suis dit il ne manquera pas
d'audace et l'audace c'est ça qui va
nous permettre d'avancer
l'audace et ce deuxième ingrédient dont
on a besoin pour bâtir ce rêve que ce
rêve montréalais et que les gens aient
confiance en eux-mêmes khaled où il est
il ait confiance en lui qui serait
capable de réussir dans l'atteinte de
ses rêves
et puis évidemment il ya un troisième
volet tout aussi important la dernière
marche du podium
pour gagner vous olympique c'est
l'ardeur l'ardeur c'est quoi c'est le
coeur au ventre labeur c'est toute
l'énergie qu'on va mettre dans un projet
l'ardeur et la passion qu'on va mettre à
faire les choses l'ardeur c'est la
motivation que l'on a transformé le
monde ya pas de miracle dans la vie y'a
beaucoup de travail comme coup de
miracle on a beaucoup de travail et ça
fait penser à une dame qui était venu
s'établir au québec une dame d'origine
haïtienne qui étaient venus s'établir au
québec
elle avait pas tous ces papiers et
finalement ça n'a pas fonctionné elle
devait quitter pour retourner en haïti
et à un moment donné quelqu'un qui a
donné de dollars avec ceux de dollars là
elle avait regardé le dollar peut rêver
dit qu'est ce que je fais que dollars
une personne que j'avais rencontré que
je vais appeler elle a pris de dollars
elle a appelé cette personne-là cette
personne qu'elle a rappelé a permis de
retourner en haïti
il faut en haïti a commencé à travailler
sur des projets d'entreprise
elle a bâti sa propre entreprise elle a
commencé à avoir des employés
elle a commencé à avoir des produits de
café des produits de chocolat des
produits de mangue et pas plus tard
qu'il ya deux mois elle est venue à
montréal rencontrer des investisseurs
parce que là elle a besoin de sous pour
croire d'autant plus son entreprise dont
elle est extrêmement fier tout ça pour
un de dollars qui avaient été données au
préalable
simplement pour dire que l'ardeur te
permet également d'accomplir énormément
d'accomplir tes rêves mais c'est cette
combinaison là qui fait en sorte qu'on
arrive finalement atteindre nos
objectifs
l'audace l'ambition l'ardeur zec nous
permet d'atteindre cet objectif
c'est ça qui nous permet de faire en
sorte que le rêve
de permettre à chacun d'émerger de créer
une société juste et équitable où tout
le monde est capable d'émerger
c'est ce qui va nous permettre et quand
chacun d'entre vous je vais reprendre la
phrase je vais le dire différemment
comme chacun d'entre vous avaient de
l'ambition de l'audace et de l'ardeur
vous avez donc également une
responsabilité une responsabilité que de
partager ça avec d'autres personnes on a
une responsabilité d'influencer les gens
qui sont autour de nous on a une
responsabilité l'influencé d'autres
sociétés comme notre société on a besoin
de rayonner partout à travers le monde
donc si vous avez ces trois caractères
cela vienne avec ces trois
caractéristiques là la nécessité de
devenir le quatrième à 1 ambassade à un
ambassadeur
le voilà qui dans cette salle s'estime
être l'ambassadeur est ce qu'elle est
mais qui ne sont pas levés qui dans
cette salle tu estimes est un
ambassadeur
monsieur vous n'avez pas lever votre
main monsieur vous n'avez pas le vénéré
madame vous n'aurez pas lever votre main
vous êtes tous les ambassadeurs les
ambassadeurs c'est quoi ce sont des gens
qui croient au morial qui ont petits
coeurs pour mon rien le petit coeur qui
bat pour montréal et qui se disent que
le rêve montréalais que d'avoir de
l'audace de l'ambition et de l'ardeur et
de permettre à toutes les clous et
d'émerger d'avoir de l'influencé sur le
reste du monde de peut-être donner une
chance un khaled et que khaled un jour
plus sortir de la vie qu'ils mènent
aujourd'hui pour aller nous inspirer
pour nous raconter comment c'était dans
des camps de réfugiés pourrait lui
raconter les problèmes de guerre civile
et ainsi de suite est influencé le reste
du monde ça fait partie de ce rêve là
que l'on caresse être ambassadeur ça
veut pas dire être une personne à
l'étranger qui connaît vaguement
montréal ça peut être toutes sortes de
personnes les ambassadeurs ça peut être
cette femme que j'ai rencontrée au
vietnam qui a bâti une entreprise de
millions de dollars aujourd'hui et qui
est venu me voir et m'a dit j'aimerais
ça pouvoir aider morjan mais je ne sais
pas comment je suis au vietnam comment
pouvez-vous et des ambassades à
ambassadeur c'est le directeur général
de l'hôtel nikko que j'ai rencontré à
tianjin en chine qui m'a dit j'aimerais
celle des mots rien mais l'aja bitan
écoute ma famille est ici comment est ce
que je peux aider en bas salat les
ambassadeurs c'est l'investisseur
chinois qui venait de faire pour la
première fois la semaine dernière
l'investissement étranger à montréal
c'est la première fois que vous allez
ses investissements hors chine première
fois qu'il venait à montréal et m'a dit
j'adore cette ville
j'adore cette ville je disais je vais
devenir un ambassadeur
l'idée là dedans c'est qu'on est tous
nous sommes tous des ambassadeurs de
cette ville qui à bien des égards est
fabuleuse
et on a le devoir d'aller raconter ce
qui s'y passe on a eu la semaine
dernière beaucoup parmi vous étaient
présents à l'événement je vois moria
nous avons réuni toutes ses forces vives
pour discuter de projets emballants plus
de 1000 personnes étaient présents il ya
également nos centres de recherche
il ya d'innovation conseil à la
créativité
que l'on a quelques sortes de choses que
l'on peut partager et inversement ils
fois que vous êtes ambassadeur et que
vous vous inscrivez à contacter moral
une fois que vous participez à ça vous
avez aussi le devoir d' influencer ce
que les uns les autres ambassadeurs
raconte ce montréalais le pouvoir
d'influencé et c'est ainsi que tourner
la roue et c'est ainsi que nous allons
être capable de continuer à poursuivre
le rêve montréalais dans quel but ultime
dans le but ultime de permettre encore
une fois à des gens comme chloé de
réussir et de réaliser ses rêves à des
gens comme khaled de les influencer pour
qu'eux aussi à travers les français il
faut se réaliser leur rêve et au bout du
compte qu'on soit capable de transformer
ce monde à notre manière et d'avoir de
l'impact sur l'ensemble de la société
merci infiniment